have you guys met mop yet oh no that's
unfortunate soon Happ hell yeah real
soon Brownsville Legends got to link up
with the Brownsville Legends we are the
Brownsville Legends so are they they
definitely a lot of respect to them
that's a fact can we talk about the song
Annie up that's your favorite song play
me this Annie Up remix that did this
crazy as [__] that [__] make me want to
go [__] horse on a [__] you
know what I'm
saying you know what I'm saying that
[__] make me want to go [__] that
[__] made me want to go do a smash and
grab at [__] Macy's bro you know that
[__] made me want to go [__] go to
the van eyes mall and get me a Rolex bro
forcefully you feel me ganga forcefully
go crazy great great song so what's uh
what's on the way obviously you guys
have been putting out singles and stuff
EP
EP sooner than you think like
Friday next Friday Friday After Next
October no date sooner than you think
first of all it sounds like he's got a
date in mind it sounds like you're full
of
[__] October time is right in October
when the time is right H it could be
tomorrow it could be tomorrow it could
be in a week it could be in a week it
could be yesterday it it couldn't be
yesterday it could be
today
what so I got a question so obviously
you guys do the EP together and you guys
have like certain songs that are like
you know one of you guys are on or two
out of the three of y'all or all three
of y'all are you guys going to end up
doing any sort of solo uh projects yeah
that's definitely after
the nice so y can really see that I feel
like each of us already have like three
solo albums if you really want to pull
all the songs together we go to the
studio every day gamer bro nice every
day you guys write your [__] down or you
do the punch in off the top what y'all
doing I
haven't me now every single time we get
in the store just put on a beat and jump
on it you just go in punch that's how
the best song made
though H you made deuce on accident oh
word yeah on accident how you make it on
accident [__] it was it was a new type of
beat like we never heard some [__] like
that before feel me so I played the beat
I'm like [__] is nigg going to do on
this played the beat my son J jacked it
and we hopped on it made that [__] in 15
minutes that [__] damn turned out to be
one of our biggest
songs we was still session was about to
be over and we just did the beat just to
do it all off the top off the top that's
why that's why I a't right after that
when they went vir I'm like nah it's
crazy I ain't even right that [__]
that's sick should just let me know we
could feel me do this sh is it going to
go more viral than him snotting all over
the mic yo it's like a
hor this is definitely
viral what's the name of the EP lose all
my [__] no you're not doing no you're
going to be all right I promise you N I
won't what is the name of they've
snotted all over you before you just
didn't know it what I mean if they were
doing their job if they were doing their
job it was a SN though a little bit NY
[__] getting punched in their face
they be slobbing yeah but what do you
think that is that's mucus that but it's
not from the nose like a sne that's
whack that's dumb dirty sneezing on me
what sneezing on
me I interviewed uh that Mexican have
you guys heard of that Mexican OT he's
the the Mexican rapper who wears no
shirt he got a cowboy hat on no he's
popping he's dope super dope y'all
should check him out he said he only
likes women who when they're done
sucking his dick it looks like they
sneezed all over his dick
sneezed could have said like anything he
said he he want like I want it to look
like that but I don't want a [__] to
actually sneeze on right gang actually
sneeze I like my [__] sloppy and messy
sloppy and messy yeah yes like like yeah
for
sure ass for
sure
isny well anyway uh what's uh do we have
a name for the EP y'all going to hear
the name when it come out it's just
going to come out like it's not even
going to be no preparation it's just
going to drop right no it's just going
we're just going to wake up it's going
to be out wake up it's y think y'all
Beyonce or
something
[__] who do y'all think y'all are like
y'all ain't going to promote your [__]
like it's just going to come out like
we're Beyonce that's what we are y'all
ain't there yet give me a date no wow
how you do me huh it's just going to
drop man so since you guys have uh been
doing a lot more better in
life what's the stupidest purchase for
each of you so
far um I buy a lot of stupid [__] n yeah
I believe you I try to save my money but
you try to save you well okay for
someone who tries to save their money
what is a dumb purchase for you
though I don't know did you ever like uh
[__] off on a chicks only fans content I
done bought the only fans before where
my mother so when you bought the only
fans did you buy the content to go like
like the little
DM what they got DM content oh I bought
tnder gold recently y was on Tinder I'm
not say oh you got Tinder gold I only
bought it to see like what it was like
like so back in the day when I was on
Tinder I had that too cuz you could do
like unlimited swipes right yeah you can
do unlimited swipes so you can like
unlimited you can like unimited what
about I mean if you're on Tinder without
tnd to go you cannot you got you got to
wait you got to unimited about the white
lights and [__] that's my thing is if
you're going to be on Tinder you got to
go gold it's no reason to you your
Tinder if you're not gold yeah cuz then
I don't think it's a reason to be on
tind the thing if you're on Tinder gold
then you just swipe on everything you're
not even looking you're just like this
and then you just see who you match with
she looks rough there's a kid with her
in the picture i' BEP I'm married now
but you know before I was married I had
Tinder gold and it was nice you was
getting [__] up there I got a few you
don't think that shut the back door the
back door like
anal Y what do you say in the back door
you haven't like at least heard what
does that mean y but what what's the
back door what are you
saying but why does everything like the
anal that's what usually when you say
the back door that's what I mean that's
your [__] right cuz yo all right
what do you mean bro the back door the
48 like the 48 set up oh you think
tinder's a setup you know I actually
heard if you go to like uh certain
countries Colombia if you go to Colombia
Andy you T they going they gonna rob you
for take you to the go [__] heard think
if a [__] SE talk all on Tinder hey hey
can we look at your Tinder profile right
now Tata while we're here I just want to
see what photos you're using
to see we got to rate these
pictures I'm just curious you don't not
on Tinder how [__] know what do you
want you got a bumble let me see let see
I
got wait I got to see oh wow hold on
this is the one right here Christian
Mingle bro this is amazing just ask
going to get robbed hold on I'm going to
hey I'm going to take a picture of this
so we can put it up on the screen right
now this picture of you flipping the
camera off with your teeth and like what
looks to be like Soulja Boy like
sunglasses bro what kind of matches are
you getting with these photos everything
no you're not getting any wifey material
with these there's no wife material
coming with those TR to tell her bro
like how was no wife material coming
with that bro oh you're you got the
[__] the Astro Boy boots on
we so what kind what kind of women are
you matching with like show the women
though some sexy Reds matching with you
for sure oh you got some Asians oh
Asians yeah what's your uh your favorite
uh type of Queen to
poach huh what is your favorite type of
Queen to poach poach I like tall girls
tall girls what's the heaviest Queen
you've ever poached n no no we don't do
no heavy we don't
do like I'm not saying if you heavy not
a queen yeah g black is beautiful I
thought but what's the heaviest Queen
you've
poached nothing over one 180
not hey hey 130 130 okay okay 180
depending on hey also depending on
height
135 [__] bro first 40 what 140 is
over my [__] be dumb thick dumb thick
180 is dumb thick trying to show
especially weight goes to that how tall
or short is she I don't really like tall
[__] so you like short 180 lb women
so your women all look like uh pinky
eight
pinky what wait talking wait who's that
y Jen what kind of women do you like I
mean I just like women that respect
himself that's a sweet answer none of
these [__] respect theel these dumb
ass
hoes about what's it like hanging out
with these misogynistic human beings
every day you're not misogynistic
what the [__] that mean he said [__]
these [__] [__] these
[__] not are you I don't find myself
with too many females cuz I don't trust
them I respect that is it is it chilling
though you be chilling yeah is it um
hard for you guys to trust women being
kind of famous I would trust no it's
even like harder I trust
nobody these [__] is [__]
bro that's good right for you they're if
they're [__] that's good yeah I don't
really give a [__] yeah damn we got to
get KY wait you just go you got to
accept the fact that feel me these hoes
is [__] man yeah everybody everybody
the Bros the Bros have you you are you
guys Eskimo brothers that mean you and
you what the [__] that mean you want to
know yeah an esimo brother means you
guys have each poached the same Queen
before oh come on
now I I a going lie esimo Bros times how
many though I got mutuals like all my
brothers I so how many uh how many women
in the world have you guys each been
inside of not at the same time of course
I just mean overall
like like I got homies around a little
too Federal my heart I got a list a list
at least like three right three to seven
three I got a list not going to lie you
have a list yeah what is your
list I tried to have a list they got I
got a list is that a list of all the
women for br what about that right after
for me they go they get added to the
list so after you [__] check cuz look
there's a there's a serious list here I
just saw serious notes you to list bro
he's got a real list with like real
notations list bro what about I got a
list what about that check you out every
time it's they get added right to the
list so and I put if I put like one one
out of 10 in
parentheses wow any sort of specific
note like uh Asian girl if it was yeah
Asian girl Tinder remember their name if
I don't know their name I put y
lightskinned shorty from wherever she
from Upper East Side white [__] eight
out of 10 and if I just got the neck if
I just C the neck I'm put in PR like
only head head rating two out of six
yeah you can't count that if it's only
high but they just get added though to
the list though like y want a list I
wish have you guys ever heard the song
by nor just called it's called head no
who is Nora noria Nora hold on
nor Nora CNN Capon Nora how you how some
go what what what what [__] oo
[__] t n y invaden y I think that's
past our generation definitely way
before uh goddamn drink Champs how' I go
nor bro drink Champs he interviews
rappers he's the drunk old uncle that
everyone loves in hip-hop I met that
[__] in La yeah no Nori stand for NWS
on the Run
eatting M he had a song called head and
it was doggy style was my favorite
position until I switched it dead [__]
got on some head [__] give me some head
you know yeah getting head in the whip
without crashing it you know I love that
have you guys ever got roadhead danger
about you got your dick sucked while
driving a Lamborghini no I was in the
back seat who was driving my manager oh
your manager
[__] yo a Lamborghini back seat's not
very spacious bro that [__] is not
spacious at all what about a thick ass
[__] what about that buck 80 she was n
not really a buck 80 like she was cool
35 4 show me your IG I got I see what
y'all doing